shipping crisis in america
today
um so there's a lot of talk about
shipping crisis and people have
different opinions
on what's going on america isn't running
out of everything just because of a
supply chain crisis america's running
out of everything because americans are
buying so much
stuff this is an insider story
and uh uh this story is coming from
warrens
that national retail federation says
okay americans aren't buying everything
they can get their hands on and they'd
be buying even more of it if it weren't
for those pesky supply chain snarls the
national federal national retail
federation said those shortages seem so
uh
uh uh you say that word right there for
ambiguous ambiguous ubiquitous
that the term everything shortage is now
being used uh
liberally to describe consumers
frustration as they try to get goods of
all sorts paper towels milk toys and
more to understand the situation
consider the country's inventory to
sales ratio this metrics tracked by the
u.s census bureau compares how much
stuff sellers have on hand on how much
stuff consumers are buying the ratio is
at a 10-year low which indicates that
we're low on stuff it's low because
sales have gone completely nuts in the
in the first nine months
of 2021 retail sales were up 14 and a
half percent over the same period in
2020 and today we have a hundred ships
waiting offshore at la porte with cargo
which is an examiner story
23 of the waiting ships are mega
containers meaning they are the largest
shipping
vessels in the world that can hold more
than a hundred of more than ten thousand
twenty foot containers ships must abide
by a set of rules which uh when picking
up a spot such as standby ship lanes and
anchoring at two miles out from all this
other stuff so anyways we hear all these
stories about shipping shortages uh two
you have some experience with this what
do you think is really going on here is
it really a supply chain crisis are we
just buying too much stuff oh i i
definitely think it's both like you
we've been doing this to ourselves for
many years outsourcing right
manufacturing right bringing it imports
instead of pushing out exports so we're
relying so much on other countries think
about what we're doing with with all the
products you know manufacturing china
manufacturing south america all these
are cheaper labor right so uh
businessman is going to want to go
and get so we've been doing this for
years growing a wealthy
uh
america right independent business
owners are getting more wealthy by
outsourcing to
foreign so we've been doing this and
this became a norm in america we've been
building this infrastructure for years
relying on external imports china built
that empire off of slave labor for
example exactly so now with with us
relying on other countries uh with kovit
hitting right kovit obviously shut down
the whole world so now we're we're that
backlog
what you're saying now patrick is like
do you think that you know america is
overspinning yes i do think that too
because we do not
okay
i feel
there's a percentage of america a large
percentage of america that does not
trust
the administration right now does not
trust the future of american or safety
of america so that's why they're going
to stock up they're going to stock up on
on water they're going to stock up
what's causing the lack of trust though
what is causing the lack of trust
i hear many different things i'm curious
what you think well you know like uh how
you know
deceitful the media is on certain things
like they're saying there's no shortage
but then we go into a grocery store
they're saying there's no shortage but
then it takes us forever to to buy
something online getting a stake these
days right so what i'm saying to you
there is a shortage and um
you know i i feel like the
administration too is kind of playing it
off
as in you know
um i mean we we heard about you know the
imports of goods and uh
you know they they made a common
administration made a comment about the
uh what the reclining chairs oh you
won't have a dishwasher
right so they're they're kind of like uh
pushing that off but america is kind of
overspinning
they're being condescending about it a
little bit right right so that but
that's why america's overspending
because they do not trust the media but
there's also a lie too because of if if
the reason why there aren't things to
buy is because we're buying so much
stuff then why is the economy booming
economy's tanking
so we're overspending why is the economy
tanking i feel economy is tanking
because we're mass reducing the american
dollar right so inflation's going
through the roof right now unemployment
is going through the roof you know i
mean um uh we're supporting the
non-working class so that's not going to
bring back our that's not going to bring
back our economy
do you guys see the county and
central coast county in california can
you pull that up central coast county in
california gas prices i posted this
yesterday
abc eyewitness news kyle texas to you
california gas prices in this county hit
no this is not an exaggeration
seven dollars and 59 cents a gallon
premium is nearly 850. i predicted 10
gas prices are coming i'm two dollars
away at that time for anybody that just
bought a ferrari premiums through the
roof
i walked here this morning it took me
seven hours i was thinking about getting
a car but not anymore well that's
definitely not gonna happen well you
brought there's two sides to this
because i i you know you brought up the
supply chain issue we talked about that
on the last podcast phil heath who i
believe you know
uh he said his mom worked in the supply
chain he had a good personal story but i
also think there's another side to this
which you
touched on
is that in america we buy a lot of
like a lot of
and you said that some of the
happiest people you've ever seen in your
day have just been the poorest people
that didn't have a lot of stuff going on
in their life and i think that you know
what i've seen is that americans
consume a lot of stuff i'm not saying
i'm a minimalist but i i definitely
gravitate towards being a minimalist not
needing the fancy stuff
to fulfill your life like it's a it's a
it's actually a scientifically proven to
be a sugar high oh i want to get this i
want to get this and three days later
you know you're super excited to get a
new pair of shoes or a new bag or new
whatever and three days later
scientifically your um
emotions or
morphines that's what i mean it's like
we look at the like bushido right
musashi said we look at the externals to
to allow us to feel something internally
right and wealth is one of them right uh
materialistic items is another one look
that's an american thing exactly okay
that's the american thing we're the
credit card we're not gonna change that
okay well this we're not gonna i don't
know if we're gonna change the entire
culture but this is where you have to
look inside
yourself and look in the mirror and say
do i really need this is buying more
stuff
really what i'm looking for in life i
get it people need the basics people
need milk people need you know gas in
this case
all the consumerism but also the
shortages it's because the gas prices
are going through the roof yeah the
shortage on truck workers and the
mandates yeah so i i feel like that's
shorting that's closing down the supply
chain as well these are two different
issues here what should you say okay so
let's just say what you're saying is
save that money fine well i'm just
saying that there's a flip side to the
supply chain stuff it's that how much
stuff do you need we're talking about
they're cancelling christmas but so
you're not getting 20 christmas presents
that's a question to say how rich is
good how rich is rich like so so
if you if you live in america the reason
why you love america is because the
person has a freedom to choose okay
america was founded on four different
things freedom to choose freedom to
freedom to buy freedom to sell freedom
to fail freedom to try buy sell try fail
it's up to you go for it's capitalism do
what you got to do you want to buy it
buy it you don't want to buy it don't
buy it it's totally up to you
this is not a
uh
philosophical conversation here about
this this is about why the hell do we
have the shortages one is saying we're
buying too much the other is saying oh
it's because
100 ships are sitting out there we can't
get it up people don't want to come in
here and work and take that stuff off
ten thousand containers that you're
talking about the biggest one they got
23 these ships are the biggest ships you
know you got jen sackey uh uh
who comes out yesterday saying when
asked about biden's supply chain crisis
saki cracks a joke at the expense of
americans this is a post-millennial
story she says it was a cl it was clear
march of 2020 when covert hit that the
supply chain across the world had been
disrupted even as a sort of work to
fight back against covet procedure
people it was crystal clear that the
that things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things so why did
uh the tragedy of the treadmills that's
delayed
she talks about and joking about it
during the pandemic many gyms were
closed et cetera et cetera so
you know this is about this christmas
people are not going to get stuff on
time and they're preparing everybody
don't expect your gifts to show up on
time
why is this happening america is not
going to change their habits overnight
that takes a generation or two to do but
this concern here you got a capitalistic
society who's accustomed to getting
products being delivered on time now
they're not yeah this isn't philosophy
this is management you know
philosophically you want to talk about
minimalism it's a different conversation
i agree yeah like this is you know the
this isn't just america this is a global
supply issue it's not like this is
immune to america yeah only in america
it's crazy it's almost like the entire
world ordinated i know it's crazy it's
almost like run nothing and behave right
because the entire world's been dealing
with a pandemic
but yeah poorly too
so listen the the la la in particular
there's the regulations are what are
shutting down the la right now it's it's
it's government that's causing a
six-month backlog it's not the pandemic
it's the government response to the
pandemic it's also a lack of workers we
discuss which is which is due to the
government response to the pandemic
you know this is it's it's it's very
very very clear
there's not a backlog in jacksonville
right now one of the biggest ports on
the east coast is there a six-month
backlog of the is the supply chain
broken and in the are you saying this is
on gavin newsom
it's on gavin newsom okay it's on bill
de blasio it's on andrew cuomo it's on
it's on people that aren't controlled
how are they how's new york affecting
l.a
de blasio this is a moment this is a
literal nationwide logistics problem
that we just said it was just fun
jacksonville is a problem jacksonville
is fine you can you can look at where
the backlog is there's a backlog in new
york harbor there's a backlog in
elizabeth there's a backlog the the la
backlog is as9 it's like six months
behind right now it's actually cheaper
for a lot of these ships to redirect
from the pacific go through the freaking
panama canal and come to the east coast
they will on they will unload quicker
than waiting in port in la
you know so
freedom to try freedom to try man listen
this this is logistics
just this morning there's a guy i had
breakfast with at my uh at my condo man
the guy sells pepperidge farm cookies
it's incredible how much money there is
in cookies man
398 was where the cookies started this
year they're up to 417. he sells them
wholesale he said they'll be five
dollars by the end by the end of the
year i mean that doesn't seem like much
that's a 33 increase in one year just
off of shipping
33 on cookies what what's milk what's
things that need to be refrigerated
cookies can stay on the shelf for two
years what are things that are
perishable i mean it's going to go
through the roof man we've only just
begun to feel the pain
look i i'm with you clearly we need our
stuff in america especially if it's
staple industry but we talked about it
takes generations to fix
well i'll flip it on you there's
somebody named marie kondo you know who
that is
who basically said
you know goes to people's houses and
says does this spark joy to you
and if not get out get rid of it sure no
matter what's going on with supply chain
and macroeconomics and tariffs or
whatever at the end of the day this
comes down to how many cookies
do you actually need okay how much extra
stuff do you need i got i get stapled
i'll put you on friday i'll put you on
front street then why do you live in
boca raton for three times the amount of
money it would cost you to go live out
in coral springs
right like you can go we can go west in
the swamps and live for five hundred
dollars if it's about efficiency yeah
how can we don't live out there you can
have like where i live yeah that's your
choice but that would be like okay
to do it that would be seen as excessive
that would i don't think that success
it's excessive as compared to buying a
single wide out in the swamps right like
i mean if everything is about efficiency
if everything if materials yeah but if
the world crumbled
and i had to go live in a smaller place
i didn't have any money i'd still be
happy
like i get it like supply like i'm not
like oh my god i have to go and move
into a smaller unit buddy i lived in a
little
shack in dallas
just to be a minimalist well you loved
it not really but i did it because i
wanted to be a part of valuetainment and
that's what i was willing to do to go
through the struggle in this case i mean
not that big of a deal but that's what i
was willing to do
but
a part of me i understand our supply
chain i get it but cry me a river if
your cookies are a dollar more bro let
me let me ask you a question kai pull up
a larger pull up the top 10 ports in the
u.s pull up the top 10 ports in u.s
top 10 ports in the u.s yeah
so let's go through so number one is
what you got la is one okay long okay
got it so hang on let me see the numbers
right there seventy five hundred acres
one of those teams of vessels 170 ml
revenues tons 276 billion dollars of
value
leading trading partners china hong kong
japan south korea 1.6 million they're
okay keep going to the next one it's our
gate to the west yep long beach
long beach's next uh
uh uh 370 okay go to next new york and
new jersey is third got it that's also
china india germany then it's georgia
port savannah and brusnick okay well
just so you know guys the number three
new york and new jersey that's actually
three separate ports there's port newark
port elizabeth and then there's port of
manhattan okay the the new york naval
lard which is actually in brooklyn got
it so you got georgia ports seattle
tacoma port so georgia gets uh
automobiles heavy machinery agriculture
products uh deep water terminals gardens
okay got it so that's coming from where
samantha's okay so then we have seattle
tacoma ports uh oil seats grains
machinery computers then we got six
port metro vancouver go to the next one
basically seattle yep virginia is next
then we have houston is eighth
go to nine and ten south carolina
oakland oakland is willing to help l.a
by the way because right now apparently
oakland is not that busy so oakland's
sending their workers right now to la to
help out
uh with the shortage that's going on
yeah so listen there's two conversations
here with what you're saying versus
what's going on one
the issue at hand is what
we we have all these ships and they're
waiting and we're gonna get that car go
out because people are running
businesses and if they don't get it and
some of the stuff that we talk about
sits there you may not even be
perishable can you sell it can you not
sell it that's a big problem right
two is a mindset about saving money
which that goes to conversation of
america being one of the worst savers in
the world well you know we're
overspenders we're constantly financing
everything which i don't uh disagree
there either we went one time to uh i
was at an island i don't know where this
was barbados i think i was at so the
driver is taking me
and uh we got 40 people in this bus he's
driving me i said so what do you do for
a living he says i'm the mayor
i said
yo they call you to me that's your
nickname he says no i'm the mayor
i said i'm serious he says i'm the mayor
of this town you're not the mayor of
this time it's not to google me you guys
that's because i'm like sitting i'm like
come on bro you i said let me see your
license as a driver he gives me less i
google i'm like mayor of this city are
you the freaking mayor
sound the marriott that's freaking sick
good for you mayor so we're driving
we're having a good time he's telling
these stories
i said so tell me how economy works here
if you want to buy a house he says you
see that house right there that was my
house i said what'd you pay for that he
said i paid 80 000 for that house some
small number not a big number i said so
when you when it comes down to financing
how do you finance that thing he says oh
there's one thing we don't do we don't
do financing here
i said how do you buy that house he says
you have to have cash
if you don't have cash you don't buy
that house what city is this this is
barbados some weird place i was out with
dave ramsey fantasyland yeah but so so i
said that jen would remember this so i
said okay so i said so you mean to tell
me anybody that buys a house or buys
cash he says anybody that buys a house
here you buy cash if you rent you rent
if you buy you buy so
that's the extreme of the complete
opposite side you have to have you want
to buy a million dollar house you got to
buy cash you want to buy six hundred
thousand dollar house you gotta buy cash
okay so now you're not happy about that
part because to you it's like wait a
minute we need financing right well
to that country
financing and being able to go finance
the million dollar loan and only put ten
percent down which is a hundred grand
and you live in a million dollar home
where you're financing nine hundred
thousand dollars making a fifty two
hundred dollar mortgage payment per
month you're being a little aggressive i
think that part needs to be a balance
when the no income no asset loans we had
and people were financing 100 we
financed 98
that was aggressive so i'm kind of with
you on a little bit more of putting up
cash to buy a house a little bit more of
less credit cards everything being debt
more buying stuff that you can afford
with your cash but at the same time
that's philosophy this is reality that's
going on today and they got to address
this they don't have a lot of time to
address this
that's a long-term fix we need a quick
short-term fix right now being positive
don't you think that's something that
will get fixed over time i get it it's
an issue right now today but don't you
think they're active i'm not even being
political here i do don't you think that
the people in charge are actually trying
to figure it out i don't know if that's
true you think they're trying to
purposely sabotage it part of the
buildback better agenda is yeah there
there's there's some odd there's so they
want sabotage no yes
i'll just i'll just say yes who wants it
there's a global community i think that
there is a push so we minimize our our
our wealth in america it's a wealth
there's nothing i don't disagree with
right so if they're able to control the
supply chain we can't buy and continue
you know uh and they're trying to save
the the earth right with the uh
climate changes by keeping these ships
out that burned out billions of gallons
of diesel well not making not running
these factories to to keep on producing
our materialistic goods right i think
that there's a lot of a lot of what
we've dealt with in the pandemic is some
sort of long play into
climate change agenda well i want to
talk about this because my grandfather
right from world war ii
so
he always told me hey you can't buy you
can't buy it unless you could pay cash
for like that kind of attitude so where
did that mindset change because if you
look at the americans that came out of
the depression that air that they grew
up in that area they're all about
minimal right living so i think that
once america goes through this just a
tip of the iceberg we're going to go
back to that same methodology i can
actually answer that question when it
changed 1978 the community reinvestment
act fannie mae freddie mac started
student loans government-backed student
loans government-backed housing
that's what started the free credit
spigot and it's only gotten worse from
there all right and credit cards came
before that well diners cars diners
clubs all diners club exactly but you
had to what you had to do to get a
credit card back in the day was insane
the credit you want to talk about income
inequality in the world
credit score you know nobody ever talks
about this ever you've never seen
anybody march against credit right isn't
that crazy nobody's ever marched against
visa nobody's ever marched against
mastercard there's never been a occupy
discover
credit score is the largest wealth
disparity in the world the wealthier you
are the more access to funds you have if
you're if you're not wealthy or if
you've struggled and you need the money
they won't give it to you but you know
listen part of that also it's really
really genius it's really genius why
they went to education first especially
when you look at the fact that they got
rid of
uh you know like scores to get into
higher education now there's no testing
in a lot of high schools they're getting
rid of the s.a.t
higher education
is not about intellect anymore it's 100
percent about obedience and the longer
you go in education the more you're
willing to put up with though it's more
of an obedience test if you get your phd
with a state school you may not have
ever been in the top echelon of your
class you just stayed in school now
think of the brilliance of that the
brilliance of having people literally
pay to do work instead of getting paid
to do work for 10 years and our society
looks at them as if they're the valiant
our society looks at a trucker a cdl
about to make 250 grand this year as if
he gave up on life he looks at somebody
that enlisted in the military as like
last ditch right but somebody that
doesn't earn anything that pays money to
do work there's somebody noble they get
a name they're a doctor they're a people
there's a flip side to the story is that
they actually have to enter the working
world at age 35 and then they get paid
hopefully a quarter million dollars half
a million dollars how's that working out
because people with masters and basket
weaving well obviously some people don't
think ahead of the roi of what you're
going to go to school for no clearly but
there's there's i believe there's a
longer strategy i think there's two
things i think there's two things i
think there's those
who maybe are uh evil uh motivations
that they have
let's just say there's a group like that
i think it's a very small community i
don't think it's as big of a community
as a small community but they got a lot
of power yeah you know i'm not
disagreeing i'm just telling you it's a
very small community that
is actually trying to do that to ruin
the western westernized philosophy
capitalism the rich all that other stuff
i think there's a flip side of it where
sometimes you do something in your life
and you didn't count all the
possibilities of negative things that
could happen and you're going to pay
some consequence suffer some
consequences and that's what's happening
right now today's a byproduct of bad
policies today's a bad bad uh byproduct
of uh
you know falling for the trap of let's
keep giving people free money today's a
byproduct of getting people not to go to
work and say no they need three more
months they need six more months keep
setting them up
we're talking about this right now and
our transportation czar is at home
yeah two two month uh uh
paternity leave two month paternity
leave uh which which
anyways two month paternity leave uh is
what they're going through while we just
had a baby did you take maternity leave
then the day i had it i was working so
but that's a different story i don't
have the luxury of being an educated
smart guy like pete you know i i don't
have the fancy degree yeah it's very
very exciting i didn't i don't have that
luxury anyways going back to it
byproduct bad policies manipulators be
on closed doors sure small community bad
policies would produce this kind of a
environment that we currently have i
don't know i don't hate the manipulators
pat i got to be honest that's their job
that's what they want to do right this
is they want to take over the world they
want fair okay that's what they want
what i
who i actually hates a strong word who i
who i really blame
i blame the useful idiot i blame the
person that goes along with the
manipulators because they just want to
fit in they don't actually look into
anything they don't they don't look at
anything other than a completely
superficial understanding of what's
happening and they want to tweet
something so their favorite celebrity
retweets them they want they want to put
social pressure on a nurse that she has
to choose a single mother nurse has to
choose between putting something in her
body that she doesn't want or losing her
job and not being able to feed her kid
the people that are pressuring her
right into doing the quote unquote right
thing those are the people i can't stand
not the manipulators at the top because
you're right it's very very very few of
them but they they manipulate the masses
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]